this is not how a secondary school with
over a thousand pupils usually looks
intern time but due to current virus I
filled Community College in crawley west
sussex is only open to the children of
key workers those who are vulnerable and
some pupils from years 10 and 12 like
other schools in England it went fully
reopen until September by then almost
nine million children will have been out
of the classroom for six months and no
schools in the UK will be fully reopened
before August it's a huge logistical
challenge for head teacher Rob Corbett
this is a standard classroom laid out as
it normally would be so this will seat
30 students comfortably I can't get 30
students in here in any way other than
no gap between them now currently our
year 10 groups are in bubbles of 12
maximum they have a maths and English
and a science lesson every day they go
home before lunch so they don't go out
breaks they don't have a lunch break
they stay within one corridor so they
they stay apart we find that this is the
maximum number of students with a two
meter width that we can fit into the
majority of our classrooms despite the
challenges mr. Corbett is keen to get
children back as soon as possible do you
think that's gonna be particular
challenges for this area because I guess
Gatwick is a really big employer Gatwick
he's the main source of jobs in the
Crawley area and with the hits the
aviation industry British Airways and
Virgen moving away from Gatwick Terr to
settle in Heathrow there is going to be
major challenges in terms of employment
going forward for our children's parents
and for them as they go into the
workplace
we have double international national
average of disadvantaged students there
fantastic young people but the
applications for free school meals have
been flooding in as jobs have been lost
in get week and that's going to have a
massive impact both on the town and the
service industries that serve the people
who work at Gatwick and on the students
themselves as you get social issues
around unemployment and the difficulty
of getting work
how hard has it been to reach those kids
and make sure that they are still being
engaged when you don't see them every
day in the classroom well we've been
phoning home very regularly making
contact but but some people down onto
the phone and they don't answer emails
and and in some households school isn't
a priority when the students are coming
into school which is why I'm an advocate
of them returning you can do things
about that you can talk to the student
you can support them you can give them
extra help you know one of the things
that we do with one of the pots of
funding is we employ our literacy
specialists who help small groups of
children to learn to read the funding
for that was cut last week for year
seven catch up and that went under the
radar and that's really important money
to schools and what we really want is is
to be given the money in the control to
be able to support the students that we
have how do you think the communication
has been from the government so far well
I think they're in a very difficult
situation and it's very easy to be
critical of people you know when when
you're in a situation without precedent
I don't think communication has been
great but I think there's been an awful
lot of working out what to do next as
opposed to having an ongoing plan of how
we think it's going to pan out and what
you need I need real clarity about how
we open in September what I really need
is an assurance that our budgets will be
kept safe over the course of the next
Parliament and when we have to face the
financial reality of what lockdown has
done to the economy that schools on
stripped of money the announcement last
week of a billion pounds for catch up
he's very welcome it's fantastic but the
suggestion that that's paying for
one-to-one tuition historically is not
proved to be particularly financially
good sense and we know our students we
know what we can give them if we got
none of that billion pounds but got the
assurance that our budgets would be
protected we would know that what our
staff capability is we would know what
the gaps are and we can match those up
the government will provide guidance on
how schools should reopen safely this
week eagerly anticipated by headteachers
if the only art of visiting this school
that I've really realized just how
impossible it will be to enforce strict
social distancing if all children are
back full-time
the question is what's more important
sticking to the social distancing rules
or getting people's back after months
and months away from the classroom and
that is a decision for the prime
minister I think if we look at how
quickly and the government was able to
construct a whole hospital think of the
Nightingale hospital within days their
questions to be reached why couldn't
have similar efforts been made for
children and for education the harms
being done by children out of the
educational system for so many months
are incredible in the sense that will
this time ever be you'll be able to get
that time back some of it is
irreversible in terms the damage being
done to children this is exactly the
worst case to have a second wave and
then possibly a second lockdown in in
the autumn going into the winter and I
think scientists are extremely concerned
about this this virus is incredibly
infectious we just have to remember that
from a handful of cases you can arrive
at thousands of cases if you know there
are no checks in place to limit the
spread and so I think this is you know
the foremost concern this is why I think
you know the summer is the time to
really crunch the curve to drive numbers
as low as possible so you're in a good
position to open schools and get schools
back up and running I think if you have
numbers circulating too high or possibly
they start to increase and creep up it
becomes difficult because you can't have
everything open and you can't have
hospitality and tourism you know and
Recreation and schools open you have to
make hard choices and it becomes a
really difficult situation because there
very few people who are lobbying for
children the government has pledged a
billion pounds to help tackle the impact
of lost teaching time including 650
million pounds to support all children
in state primary and secondary schools
plus 350 million pounds to provide
tuition for the most disadvantaged
pupils but critics say there's been a
failure of leadership I don't think it's
been led particularly well I think much
of it has been inept and that must that
must stop head teachers must
confidence in the leadership of the of
the department's ability school schools
succeed or fail on on on the basis of
whether it's it's got strong leadership
and the same with the Department of
Education and you know head teachers
have got to know who's running things is
it number ten or is it always the
Department of Education a huge number of
children over two million children are
getting less than an hour's work a day
and that their online programs are
nowhere near attic adequate and the
consequences for youngsters particularly
those from poor backgrounds the
consequences for our society and for our
education system is going to be profound
and we need to recognize that everyone
involved in education needs to recognize
that and put in large scales large scale
recovery and remedial programs to make
sure that the great gains that we've
made over the last few years are not
lost and that are poor tune in
particularly a make up lost ground if
that doesn't happen and we will go
backwards and there will be all sorts of
problems in terms of social unrest
violence among amongst young people that
we've not seen before the balance
between getting children back in the
classroom while suppressing the spread
of coronavirus has been one of the
biggest challenges of the pandemic the
long-term impact on the education and
well-being of our young people is harder
to quantify than the economic hit of
lockdown but it could be just as
long-lasting